this is a new generation of aircraft and
they can be used in different ways but
they also offer a significant Market
opportunities this applies both for the
manufacturing industry for the tertiary
sector and also for our internal market
and and also beyond our borders
technology will create jobs and growth
like the mobile phones in the 90s drones
are a platform for Innovative
technological applications from energy
provision satellite coverage and yes
also transport
we need to avoid the burden some formal
certification process in every member
State use a single terminology and
conduct policies on the basis of the
same principle and of course the safety
the Danish position is that as well as
coming up with effective rules the
commission should provide support
industry in developing European product
standards for civil drones
the legislation of the EU should not
make it possible for them to be
constructed by lay persons the issue of
safety of civil aviation is not only
related to harmonized requirements for
rpas's
it is important that the needs of both
civil and Military Aviation are taken
into account equally and safely
we do consider that the commission's
plan for the integration of our pass
into European airspace from 2016 onwards
is highly ambitious given the need for
further research and development of
associated Technologies
we need to take into account other
important elements such as data and
privacy protection and security
however we believe that there is no need
for development of new rules on this
area but instead we should facilitate
the application of the existing
framework on data protection and
security
we agree with the idea that unmanned
aircrafts can
make use of the open airspace in Europe
however attention needs to be drawn to
the fact that not all rules of
traditional civilian
air flights can be applied to drones the
EU level rules must also take into
account criteria such as what type of
operation we are talking about as well
as risks limited to this distribution of
legal competencies the risks involved
are quite High
we think that the legislative
frame currently does not cover
appropriately all the possible abuses uh
in the way these systems might be used
and we feel that further improvements
should be made uh to these systems
common European should be opened
RPA
and we can support the idea that this
system should be integrated in the civil
aviation airspaces as well but for this
we need a single set of rules at EU
level this would deal at an appropriate
level with Aviation safety Aviation
Security and data protection and risks
to Citizens rights
importance to the issue of privacy and
data protection
a legislative proposal has been
announced for next year my delegation
will be very keen to work further on
this under the Luxembourg presidency and
we will be cooperating closely with our
latrian and and Dutch Partners on this
as you many of you mentioned we must now
find the right balance what
can be done what should be done and what
must not be done at European level and
clearly there is an issue of safety so
everybody must be sure that all our
airspace in in this sense is is safe
that that the airports you cannot land a
airplane cannot land and be some kind of
on the risk to to to meet some remotely
or unmanned unmanned Aviation that's
machine remotely piloted the aircraft
system